des étudiants en techniques policières
terminent leur année scolaire ils ont
appris les facettes du métier quand elle
voit des arrestations musclées dans les
médias suzie jomphe crois que les
policiers pourraient être munis de
caméra pour enregistrer leur
intervention ça peut faire un disque
qu'elle policiers intervient on le voit
pas son esprit et c'est justement ce que
réclame des associations de policiers
avoir la possibilité de capter les
interventions sur vidéo
une façon pour eux d'avoir des preuves
mais aussi distille de calmer le jeu
à partir du moment où les policiers et
fendre le citoyen intercepté qu'il est
enregistré et ou filmer ça fait baisser
de beaucoup le taux d'agressivité des
projets pilotes ont lieu à calgary
edmonton et victoria à montréal
des policiers à vélo ont déjà été
aperçue avec des appareils sur leur
casque les spvm évaluent encore s'il a
les moyens une courette achats se et
c'est pas le coût de l'achat des caméras
il faut gérer les images par la suite
cet avocat spécialisé dans les causes
impliquant des policiers est d'accord
avec l'idée d'un projet pilote au québec
il relève toutefois qu'il y aurait un
problème si ce sont les politiques qui
doivent eux-mêmes déclencher
l'enregistrement policier sait qui c'est
qui s'en est quelque chose de pas car
ils vont arrêter et où il partira pas sa
caméra
selon ce représentant des policiers de
la sûreté du québec
il faut que les agents aient le contrôle
de ce qu'ils enregistrent je m'envoie
rencontre un voisin qui veut me donner
des informations confidentielles par
rapport à l'autre voisin qui abuseraient
exemple de son enfant il ya des
informations qui doit pas être filmés au
québec
un comité d'experts se penche sur la
question faut s'assurer que il ya quand
même une protection des renseignements
privés
les recommandations sont attendues à la
fin octobre ici françois cormier radio
canada montréal